who would you want to go to dinner with
these have
these have so long and just playing
against people from different
Generations so he definitely has the
most stories and that would make for the
most interesting person to eat dinner
with okay let's see because she's
extremely interesting person and I mean
he's extremely experienced in life and
in chess and I mean he's a very very
nice person to chat with I guess Vichy
because he's very educated and he's
always a pleasure to talk to you can
learn from him I'll say Magnus I wanna
be there in this awkward silence just
watch him suffer he's a what the hell am
I doing here I'm gonna watch him and
make him suffer and he'd be like I think
you're done I'm like no I think let's
have some coffee or tea or you want some
dessert no I do want some dessert they
have excellent cheesecake in this place
did you know that and then afterwards
I'll be like I had a tea you know
dinner felt like it was hours ago let's
just start all over and you know I think
it's gonna take a while there yeah